Frauen und Männer haben
verschiedene Gehirne. Noch Fragen?
Alles klar, oder? Ok. Tschö.
Ok, ok, wir reden drüber.
Nehmt euch 'n Tee. Setzt euch.
*Titelmusik*
Freunde der Sonne,
wir kennen die Klischees.
Frauen reden viel, Männer nicht.
Frauen sind empathischer.
"Ich versteh dich."
Männer rationaler.
"Ich versteh Mathe."
Frauen können kein Auto fahren.
Männer können nicht zuhören.
"Was?"
Klischees
stellen nie die Realität dar, klar.
Wir sind alle Menschen,
die in keine Schublade passen.
Aber wenn man statistisch
die Massen betrachtet,
verhalten sich Frauen und Männer
unterschiedlich.
Gesellschaft und Kultur haben
einen wesentlichen Einfluss darauf.
Aber gibt es auch
einen biologischen Grund
für das unterschiedliche Verhalten?
Ich erzähle euch gleich was
über die Hirnstrukturen
von Männern und Frauen.
Aber damit wir uns wirklich auf die
Wissenschaft konzentrieren können,
müssen wir ganz kurz
über das hier reden.
Sagen wir, ich bin gut in Chemie.
*Gesang: "Fresh, fresh, fresh"*
Dann kann das umweltbedingt sein,
sprich: ich wurde so erzogen.
Ich wurde gefördert, gebildet,
ich hab mir Sachen angeeignet.
Oder mein Talent für Chemie
ist genetisch,
also in meiner DNA kodiert.
Alles, was genetisch ist,
damit werden wir geboren.
Alle Eigenschaften,
die etwas mit Persönlichkeit
oder Intelligenz zu tun haben,
sind sowohl von der Umwelt,
als auch von unseren Genen geprägt.
Darüber
hab ich bereits lang und breit
in unserem Video zu Erblichkeit
von Intelligenz gesprochen.
Trotzdem
analysieren Sozialwissenschaftler
oder Psychologen unsere Umwelt,
also unsere Gesellschaft,
um nachzuvollziehen,
wie z. B. Gender-Unterschiede
entstehen.
Warum sollte man
nicht ebenso schauen,
ob es genetische Unterschiede gibt?
Weil solche Forschungsergebnisse
leicht missbraucht werden können.
Bzw. sie werden missbraucht werden.
Ziemlich sicher.
Es wird immer Menschen geben,
die gesellschaftliche Entscheidungen
treffen möchten,
auf Basis unserer Biologie.
Doch wer das tut,
vereinfacht diese hochkomplexe
Biologie so stark,
dass es nicht
wissenschaftlich korrekt ist.
Doch gerade weil es
so leicht missverstanden ist,
finde ich es wichtig, dass
dieses Thema unter Wissenschaftlern
und unter Science-Freunden
kein Tabuthema ist.
Und dass wir es auch hier,
im Kreise der Freunde der Sonne,
der Freunde der rationalen Diskussion
besprechen.
Und zwar unaufgeregt
und differenziert.
Also... Shall we?
Das Gehirn
ist ein faszinierendes Organ.
Es kann verblüffende
kognitive Leistungen vollbringen.
Doch eine seiner größten
Herausforderungen ist es,
sich selbst zu verstehen.
Da verstehen wir
noch so einiges nicht.
Unser Gehirn besteht aus Neuronen,
also Nervenzellen,
die feuern elektrische Signale.
Und sie kommunizieren untereinander
durch Moleküle und Ionen.
Unsere Gedanken
sind nicht einfach materielos,
sondern sie sind grundbiologisch.
Alles Psychologische
ist auch gleichzeitig biologisch.
Es sind alles zelluläre,
molekulare Prozesse.
Nur verstehen wir unser Gehirn
halt einfach noch nicht gut genug.
Wenn ich mir
eine Gehirnstruktur ansehe
und ein Neurologe wäre,
dann könnte ich daraus nicht ablesen,
welche Gedanken
dieses Gehirn produziert.
Wir wissen nur,
dass das zusammenhängt.
Das Gehirn ist außerdem plastisch.
Das heißt, es bilden sich unser Leben
lang neue Verknüpfungen.
Wenn ich etwas Neues lerne,
verändert sich meine Hirnstruktur.
Zitat:
Im Gehirn liegt also die Ursache
für unser Verhalten.
Doch durch unser Verhalten wird unser
Gehirn auch fortlaufend verändert.
Daraus folgt jetzt
etwas ziemlich Wichtiges.
Nämlich: im Gehirn ist biologisch
nicht dasselbe wie von Natur aus.
Im Gehirn kann biologisch
sowohl genetisch
als auch umweltbedingt sein.
Ok, was ist jetzt der Unterschied
zwischen Frauen und Männern?
Männer haben in der Regel
größere Gehirne als Frauen.
Hier die Ergebnisse
aus der bisher umfangreichsten Studie
auf diesem Gebiet, die erst vor
wenigen Monaten veröffentlicht wurde.
In blau seht ihr die Größenverteilung
der Männergehirne.
In rot die der Frauengehirne.
Das ist nicht ungewöhnlich,
weil Männer generell
größer sind als Frauen.
Früher war das größere Männergehirn
Grund genug zur Annahme,
dass Männer intelligenter seien
als Frauen.
Heute wissen wir zwar,
dass das nicht stimmt,
aber die Sache mit der Gehirngröße
ist gar nicht so trivial.
Denn mehr Hirnmasse
bedeutet auch mehr Neuronen.
Es ist nur nicht klar, was die Männer
mit den Extra-Neuronen machen.
Experten streiten darüber,
wie man absolute
und relative Hirnmasse
am sinnvollsten interpretiert.
Vielleicht wird man schlauer,
wenn man sich
einzelne Hirnregionen anschaut.
Paar Ergebnisse aus derselben Studie:
Die meisten Hirnregionen
sind bei Männern ebenfalls größer.
Ihr müsst das so verstehen:
Alles, was blau gefärbt ist, ist
bei Männern größer als bei Frauen.
Alles, was rosa gefärbt ist, ist
bei Frauen größer als bei Männern.
Und je kräftiger die Farbe,
desto größer der Unterschied.
Volumen und Oberfläche
ist in den meisten Hirnregionen
bei Männern größer als bei Frauen.
Dafür haben Frauen an einigen Stellen
einen dickeren Kortex.
Der Kortex ist die äußere Schicht
des Gehirns.
So viel zu den absoluten Werten.
Teilt man jetzt diese Werte
durch die Gesamtgröße des Gehirns,
betrachtet man also relative Größen,
werden die Unterschiede
nicht nur geringer.
Ihr seht,
die Farben werden viel blasser.
Sondern
sie kehren sich teilweise sogar um.
Es macht einen großen Unterschied,
wie man diese Daten auswertet.
Also ob man absolute
oder relative Größen vergleicht.
Aber die spannende Frage ist doch,
was sagt das Ganze
über die Funktionalität aus?
Größe allein sagt uns nicht viel,
aber es gibt da was anderes.
Man kann sich das Gehirn
wie ein Netzwerk vorstellen.
Und man kann messen,
wie stark verschiedene Regionen
miteinander vernetzt sind.
Selbe Studie, anderes Experiment.
Ihr seht verschiedene Hirnregionen.
Die Verbindungen zeigen an,
wie stark die Regionen
miteinander vernetzt sind.
Blau heißt, dass die Verknüpfung bei
Männern stärker ist als bei Frauen.
Rot anders rum. Hier ist
die Verknüpfung bei Frauen stärker.
Und je kräftiger die Farbe,
desto größer der Unterschied
zwischen den Geschlechtern.
Damit knüpfen die Forscher
an diese Studie aus dem Jahr 2013 an.
Hier wurde beobachtet,
dass Männerhirne
stärker innerhalb
der Hirnhälften vernetzt sind,
hier dargestellt
mit blauen Vernetzungen.
Frauenhirne hingegen
eine stärkere Vernetzung
zwischen den Hirnhälften haben.
Dargestellt mit orangen Vernetzungen.
In früheren Studien
ließen sich bei Frauen
bessere sprachliche
und soziale Fähigkeiten messen.
Bei Männern bessere motorische
Fähigkeiten und räumliches Denken.
Doch ist das jetzt
ein neurologischer Beweis
für diese Unterschiede?
Allein diese Fragestellung
wurde von Kritikern der Studie,
von anderen Fachexperten,
als "neurosexistisch" bezeichnet.
Puh! Wer hätte gedacht,
das Science so viel Drama hat.
Wie ich das einordne, werde ich euch
gleich ausführlicher erzählen.
Aber vorher müssen wir uns noch
eine Sache klarmachen.
Im Durchschnitt
mag es Unterschiede geben.
Aber mit Ausnahme
von der absoluten Hirngröße
gibt es bei allen Merkmalen
größere Überschneidungen
als Unterschiede.
Quantitativ gesprochen haben
Männer und Frauen mehr gemeinsam,
als sie unterscheidet.
Wir sind alle nur Homo sapiens.
Was erwartet man auch?
Außerdem ist jeder Mensch
in seiner Persönlichkeit
natürlich hochindividuell.
Das zeigt auch diese Studie hier.
Hier wurden nämlich Männer
und Frauen nicht als
eine große Kurve
jeweils zusammengefasst.
Sondern die Forscherinnen schauten
sich jeden Teilnehmer individuell an.
Um herauszufinden, ob es prinzipiell
zwei Arten von Gehirnen gibt.
Ein "männliches"
und ein "weibliches".
Die Wissenschaftlerinnen
konzentrierten sich
auf bestimmte Merkmale
wie z. B.
die Größe bestimmter Hirnregionen.
Sie wählten sich
um die zehn Merkmale aus
und zwar diejenigen,
bei denen die Unterschiede zwischen
Männern und Frauen am größten waren.
Für jedes Merkmal
bezeichneten sie das eine
extreme Drittel als typisch männlich.
Das andere extreme Drittel
als typisch weiblich.
Und alles dazwischen als Mischzone,
also weder männlich noch weiblich.
Dann erstellten sie
drei verschiedene Hirn-Kategorien.
Erstens, ein typisch männliches
oder typisch weibliches Hirn.
Ein typisch männliches Hirn
hat nur typisch männliche Merkmale
neben Mischmerkmalen.
Zweitens Mischhirn.
Mischhirne
besitzen nur Mischmerkmale,
sind also generell nicht typisch
für das ein oder andere Geschlecht.
Und drittens Mosaik-Hirne.
Mosaik-Hirne besitzen sowohl
typisch männliche
als auch typisch weibliche Merkmale.
Dann schauten sie sich
individuelle Menschen an
und ordneten jeden Menschen in
eine dieser drei Hirn-Kategorien ein.
Sie werteten
unterschiedliche Datensätze aus.
Dabei stellten sie fest,
je nach Datensatz,
hatten gerade mal
0 bis 8 % der Probanden
ein typisches Gehirn, also typisch
männlich oder typisch weiblich.
Ein wesentlicher Teil,
je nach Datensatz 23 bis 53 %,
hatten Mosaikhirne.
Und der Rest hatte Mischhirne.
Diese Studie wurde in den Fachkreisen
von manchen gelobt,
sorgte aber auch für viel Aufruhr.
Es gab mehrere öffentliche,
schriftliche Auseinandersetzungen.
Statements, Replies, Drama!
Ich hab mir
eine Tüte Popcorn geschnappt
und alles aufmerksam durchgelesen.
Und bei mancher valider Kritik
bleibt am Ende der Schluss:
So etwas wie ein männliches Gehirn
und ein weibliches Gehirn
scheint es nicht zu geben.
All das ist bisher
nur Grundlagenforschung,
die versucht,
Unterschiede festzustellen
und nicht, sie zu erklären.
Schließlich sprechen wir hier nur
von einzelnen Features des Gehirns.
Von Größen verschiedener Regionen,
von der Art und Weise,
wie sie miteinander verknüpft sind.
Das alles beschreibt noch lange nicht
das Gehirn in seiner Vollständigkeit.
Geschweige denn Gedanken, Verhalten,
Fähigkeiten, die daraus entstehen.
Beispiel: sagen wir, ich entwickle
ein neues Medikament im Labor.
Und dieses Medikament
ist wirksam in einem Zelltest.
Dann ist das 'ne Supernachricht,
aber ich muss dann trotzdem
noch viel mehr Zelltests machen.
Und Tierversuche
und klinische Studien.
Zu diesem Zeitpunkt
würde niemand auf die Idee kommen,
dieses Medikament direkt
auf den Markt zu bringen. Richtig?
Und genauso wenig sollte man
biologische Grundlagenforschung
in der gesellschaftlichen Praxis
auf Gender-Diskussionen anwenden.
Aber warum erforscht man
das Ganze dann überhaupt?
Gute Frage!
Die Gelenkkrankheit Arthrose
ist bei Frauen
deutlich häufiger als bei Männern.
Ein Zeichen dafür,
dass biologische Unterschiede
zwischen Frauen und Männern
über die Geschlechtsorgane
und Sexualhormone hinausgehen.
Frauen leiden häufiger an Alzheimer,
Depressionen und Angststörungen.
Männer leiden häufiger an Autismus,
Schizophrenie und Legasthenie.
Es kommt immer mal vor,
dass Medikamente wieder
vom Markt genommen werden müssen.
Weil in der breiten Anwendung
Nebenwirkungen auftreten,
die man vorher nicht erwartet hat.
Sehr oft sind diese Nebenwirkungen
für Frauen riskanter als für Männer.
2013 musste
die Amerikanische Arzneimittelbehörde
die Dosierung für das Schlafmittel
Ambien runterregulieren.
Die zugelassene Dosis
ist jetzt für Frauen
gerade mal halb so groß
wie für Männer.
Weil der Wirkstoff bei Frauen
langsamer verstoffwechselt wird,
so dass sie leichter überdosieren.
Es gibt die Vermutung,
dass das Problem bereits im Labor,
bei der Medikamentenentwicklung
anfängt.
Genauer gesagt bei den Tierversuchen.
Die meisten Tierversuche
sind Mausversuche.
Sehr oft arbeitet man lieber
mit männlichen Versuchstieren
als mit weiblichen.
Weibliche Labormäuse
haben einen Menstruationszyklus
von ungefähr einer Woche.
Und bei diesem ganzen Hormonhaushalt
ist das eben nicht ganz so einfach,
systematische Experimente
durchzuführen.
Ist es also ein medizinischer Fehler,
das männliche und weibliche Gehirn
als biologisch gleich zu behandeln?
Es ist zumindest ein ernstes Risiko,
das m. E. erforscht werden sollte.
Ich finde es so gut,
dass ihr dazu bereit seid,
nicht den einfachsten Weg zu gehen,
dass ihr nicht
vor Komplexität zurückschreckt
und dass ihr euch so ein Video
bis hierhin anschaut.
Ihr seid wahre Science-Freunde,
Freunde der Sonne.
Deshalb freu ich mich,
eure Kommentare zu lesen,
denn ich weiß, dass diese Community
dazu in der Lage ist,
unaufgeregt und sachlich
zu diskutieren
über ein
grundwissenschaftliches Thema,
das nur dann zur Kontroverse wird,
wenn man die Wissenschaft übergeht.
Indem man zu sehr vereinfacht
oder voreilige Schlüsse zieht.
Und alle, die jetzt noch da sind,
können noch mitkommen
in die End Card.
Als echte Freunde der Sonne
habt ihr bestimmt gemerkt,
dass ich eine Woche länger
Sommerpause genommen habe
als angekündigt.
Weil einfach so viel bei mir los war
und ich diese Woche gebraucht habe,
damit ich ab jetzt
wieder geilen Content liefern kann.
Ich bin zurück, ich freu mich,
und ich bin auch wieder zurück
bei Social Media.
Da hab ich eigentlich auch
eine Art Pause gemacht.
Ich war sehr wenig online die letzten
Wochen, das war auch ganz schön.
Aber ab jetzt könnt ihr mir wieder
folgen, es lohnt sich wieder.
Wir sehen uns nächsten Donnerstag.
Bis dahin, bleibt sicher.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2018)